[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Rachel Cruz
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author co-host of the smart
money happy hour my daughter is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the show where we love you so
much we will tell you the truth
and sometimes you won't like it but
we're here because we care about you and
we're going to help I'll say I'll say
nice I'll say the say the truth nicer
than maybe he will sometimes Maybe
sometimes I'm nicer we're matching today
I just saw this in the camera little
black action here color color
coordinating yeah you know what makes
you look thinner than wearing black what
being thinner
I discovered that that's a personal
revelation of mine
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Mary is starting
us off in St Louis hi Mary welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for to my call sure
what's up
so the last few weeks uh to be honest
I've gone down a little bit of a Dave
Ramsey rabbit hole on YouTube so I'm
just kind of getting to know your
principles I'm really intrigued by them
uh but I have a real question about your
baby steps the one thousand dollar
emergency fund philosophy I think my
husband and I might be a little out of
whack when it comes to following the
steps um exactly correct we have a
sixteen thousand dollar car loan we have
a 215 000 mortgage and we have about 30
000 in non-retirement Investments
um and we've also started a few small
investment accounts for our children
we're trying to increase our retirement
to 15. we're kind of trying to do
everything at one time yeah
um my question they did all of that long
before you even heard of us
yeah
we've been trying
to really you know try to pay off as car
loans and things like that so we have
one car left
um my question is this it's taken us
several years to save that money that we
have and then non-retirement investment
and we currently have a deck in our
backyard that is literally falling apart
so we've been quoted to remove it and
replace it with a patio for about
fifteen thousand dollars what's your
household income
uh about 145. okay cool
um so I guess my question is and I you
know I also am worried if we use the
money to pay off the car loan and then
we do the patio I just always like
having some cushion to know that if
there are big purchases that come up
um that we have enough cash to do it and
so I guess I just wanted to know what
your philosophy was on based on
everything you know where we're at
um the summary of the background of the
baby steps was this when I first started
teaching uh basic financial principles
30 years ago I would have this exact
conversation with people where do I
start where do I start where do I start
and uh a couple of philosophies emerged
as we worked with thousands and
thousands of people now millions of
people years later but uh the
philosophies uh number one that emerged
was the number one wealth building tool
that you have is your income when you
give it to other people in the form of
payments you limit our slow down or even
stop your ability to build wealth
so becoming debt free first personal
later home is an essential part of a
long-term wealth building plan because
the money you make 145 000 should turn
you into a millionaire
okay if you don't give it all to someone
else in the form of car payments etc etc
right and that's the general philosophy
okay the general philosophy number two
was people kept saying where do I start
because one hundred percent of us
including no matter how much money you
make
uh have competing priorities we have a
broken down deck we have a uh a uh an
emotional need for a pad of an emergency
fund laying there
um we have high school kids they're
gonna be going to college soon college
kids coming at us we've got life
insurance we need we've got a next car
we might need to purchase we've got
another thing we've got to think about
Christmas God it's going to be here
again in 20 minutes you know and we've
got all these things coming at us and so
the what we came up with was the baby
steps and the reason they've been so
successful is because it gives you a
very clear path
uh that is based in good solid financial
planning principles
and get out of debt philosophy and it's
the shortest distance between where you
are and wealth now that it might not be
are and a deck
but it's the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth and that's what
the whole thing's built on and so what
we would tell you to do is have a
thousand dollars first any other
non-retirement money you have the thirty
thousand bucks in your case would be to
come become debt free except your home
so we pay off your car by the time you
by the time dinner is here tonight pay
off the car okay then that leaves you um
fourteen thousand dollars and you have a
debt problem and you make 145 000 so we
need to get a deck fixed you have any
money in savings at all other than this
non-retirement
um we have about
um we have a small savings account it's
about five thousand right okay so I
would keep some of that other though but
instead of the deck for your emergency
fund because when you said I just want
to have some cushion that's what that
provides you and then you guys make
great money and I would just cash flow
put in yeah put in the budget hey we're
gonna save x amount per month towards
the deck and let's pretend okay so you
make 100 you're right Richard you make
145. let's call 20 000 your emergency
fund which would probably be about right
and you never touch that ever for
anything it's not for purchases yep a
bass boat another car is not an
emergency
okay okay this is only if the world come
to an end I mean only if the
transmission goes out only if your
mother or your relative or whoever in
another state passed away and you got to
buy an airline ticket I mean only as an
emergency an unexpected event a deck
falling off is gradual that's not
unexpected yeah okay so to Rachel's
point we're gonna put 20 000 bucks there
now you got no car payment and now
you're going to get on a detailed budget
and start working these plans I and I
would save up for that deck very rapidly
I think you can save for that deck by
Christmas
okay and and then you pay cash for it oh
by the way in the winter the guys aren't
working as much
in St Louis
and so you might get a better deal
yeah okay then a deck in the summer I
could be wrong but I think so and so and
so on okay now we got a deck and now we
got baby step five fours fifteen percent
of your income going into retirement you
already got the kids college going you
already got that going and now let's
start just thinking about how are we
going to knock out this little 215 000
mortgage there's not much you sound
young how young are you I'm 34. yeah
yeah so I mean you got the same age
right so yeah
um 35 35 basically it's just close
enough yeah but I mean that's when
you're my age it's really cool
yeah so anyway the point is the uh uh uh
you know you're gonna
gosh you should have this house paid off
before you're 40. yeah you're going to
see a lot of traction Mary because you
guys you already have the Instinct
you've been doing this and like you said
it's everything's a little bit all over
you just need more of a concise plan but
there's no power and you're going to see
it in lack of focus focusing and working
straight down those baby steps gives you
a power uh because it keeps you from
doing other stuff when you try to do six
things at once nothing gets done
but you can do one thing you can get the
one thing done and so we got the car and
we got the deck now we got the
retirement we got the kids college going
now we're gonna start working on the
house one thing
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America I'm Dave Ramsey your host
hi coming up is Jackson Michigan Mike's
on the line hey Mike how are you
good Dave how about you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
quick question for you I am retired we
are retired and we have note that and
we're purchasing a new car and we can
pay cash for the new car uh if we could
get a financing deal and we can invest
that same amount of money in CDs for
that same period of time what's your
recommendation
pay cash for the car or don't buy it
okay yeah okay here's the thing okay how
much what's your net worth
uh about 2.5 million yeah you didn't get
that by playing games like this
you know well you got this by saving
money
and investing money
right but you didn't borrow on uh a car
and invest the difference
no what I was talking about is I don't
know what you're talking about but I
mean my point is is you steadily
invested over a long period of time to
get 2.5 million you did not borrow money
and invest borrowed money to become a
multi-millionaire did you correct
correct and and now you're going back on
all your old ways don't do it Go stick
with the plan that got you here you're
incredible man congratulations hero
thank you I wish I would have found you
a lot earlier it would have made the
path a little bit easier but I enjoy
your shows I don't think it's ever easy
but you you scored touchdown in the
Super Bowl as far as I'm concerned my
man well done
thank you works hard to get there thank
you very much that's so cool you know
it's funny that uh Rachel when you start
paying attention to money and obviously
that's one of the things that's required
to end up with two and a half million
dollars
I kind of thought he was going to tell
me that by the way yeah
um kind of felt it and you know he's
just like hey but the people just you
you're they're thinking about money not
in the negative way not in a greedy way
not I'm obsessed with money but instead
of just you know it's like people that
drive and pay attention when they're
driving
and the ones that drive and don't pay
attention when they're driving and
that's what they do with their money
they don't pay attention or they do and
the ones that do pay attention if you
just think about it even though he was
getting ready to do a dumb thing but I
mean he he's a guy that thinks about it
that's why he won yeah that's why he won
and and I think this is where people can
overthink something and take the math of
something and think okay well I can kind
of beat the system here because we hear
that all the time right paying off your
house or even debt you know people use
debt and want to keep debt around
because like well if I invested that
amount of money instead of paying it off
I would make more and you know I mean
like they start to they start to
overthink it where I'm always like oh my
gosh you have to like untangle it in
almost in a sense remember what brought
you here yes and what is the emotion
that you have when you're not attached
to debt what is how do you feel and that
behavior part I feel like some people
you know jump but I but I appreciated
this question because I mean I think
there are people naturally that are like
I want to do well with money what's my
what what's the quickest path
point A to point B exactly exactly
you're exactly right and and so
sometimes what can happen is you try to
fix something with the math
and you forget the heart that's right
you you know use only your brain and not
your heart because your heart measures
risk and your head does math
and so if you're if you you know oh I
work so hard to be debt free and then
all of a sudden you forget and go back
into debt on a car oh so so absurd when
you think about it right but but at
least he's on Pat task and he's thinking
about he's a person that considers these
things and is asking questions yeah
absolutely I'm still curious yeah still
curious yeah two and a half million
dollars in Well Done sir well done I'm
proud of you Stephen is in Cincinnati
Ohio hi Stephen welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave how are you better than we
deserve what's up good good I had a
question for you I'm well versed in your
program
um I'm 52
and I've got three boys one is a junior
in college or is going to be a junior
the other one is going to be a freshman
in college and the other one's just
going into high school he's not far off
from college either my wife and I have
made the decision to try to pay their
tuitions in full good and we've got yeah
we've got good 529 programs but they're
just not going to cover all of it
so we're trying to make up some ground
in a fairly short period of time
and I wanted to see what your thoughts
are on basically moving the principle
that we've paid into our Roth retirement
accounts and moving that over to the 529
it's about a hundred and ten thousand
that would basically
kind of get the deal done and Iran you
know we ran the hypotheticals I'm still
going to have about 2.2 million dollars
when it comes to retirement time which
is more than enough for for our
lifestyle so just want to get your
thoughts on that
um
how much money is in your retirement now
about 900 000. okay
and you don't have any other money
I've got our emergency funds well you're
saying pay in full Stephen you mean just
like semester by semester right
correct for all three boys for all four
years what's your household income
150 000.
um go ahead well I just want to make
sure Stephen that yeah you're I mean you
guys will pay each semester when the
semester comes you're not looking how
much is in the 529
yeah
uh let's see
there's about a hundred and ten thousand
in there now okay
and What's the total What's the total
budget for the kids to go to school the
tuitions
uh they're about let's see
a 45 a year or yeah about 45 a year for
each kid
that includes dorm and and everything
yeah that's that's everything so you
weren't talking about just tuition
you're covering everything
correct okay and so you got 80 a year
right now
correct and you got 110 in there so you
got a Year's worth you don't have enough
even if you move the Roth
uh well no so we can get out we'll
continue to stay for our youngest
but we will basically you know fund that
difference yeah but you don't have
enough even if you move the Roth because
you're you're burning the 80 a year uh
for the next two years that's 160 and
after that you're burning another 80 or
in college only two I know two are in
college now 40 each
right
yeah that's right yeah 40 each yeah so
80k per year
and you got a freshman and you got a
junior so for the next two years that's
160. you only got 210.
well we'll cash flow some of it so yeah
the math isn't Apples to Apples you're
not gonna get there you're not gonna get
there
um
so you're a freshman when you're
freshman graduates will you have another
we have two in school like ever again or
is it the one going to leave about the
time the other one comes in
the the one leaves as soon as the other
one comes in yeah okay so you're gonna
be once you get past this two years
you're at a 40 a year burn rate give or
take correct correct and that doesn't
count them getting a job which they need
to do
um and and applying for scholarships
which they need to do
right
um
I just I it just I it just goes against
everything I am and start Cashing Out
retirement for college
um I'm certainly not gonna borrow to do
it so I do that before I'd borrow and by
the way you can't roll a Roth into a 529
you can just cash it out
correct yeah so it's not you said I'll
put it in the 529 you can't but you can
just take it out and spend it and I
wouldn't do that until I'd emptied the
I'd let it sit there and grow grow
additional growth before you move it
tax-free right
and so you got I'm gonna try to make it
two more years and get that get the
first one out of school
and then get down to the 40 burn rate if
you got down to the 40 burn rate with
this money
that'll get no that just makes it one
year all right
yeah it's interesting to me it's the you
know it's a it rubs me the wrong way
because it's kind of against the
principle it's against everything I
believe yeah I'm gonna do everything I
can to not do it so so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm going to use the 529 I'm
going to cash flow like a bandit and and
I'm gonna put kids to work and I'm gonna
go for scholarships and try to not touch
this if you do touch it make it the last
thing you do and you allow it to sit
there and grow until then so maybe only
in the uh fourth or fifth year or
whatever else what else can we sell do
we have any other assets do we have
anything we can do because this hundred
thousand is worth millions if you'll
leave it alone and not take it out of
there what's your what it's going to
cost you and Miss is just ridiculous
because you're getting tax-free growth
on it I hate to touch it I really hate
to touch it so it'd be the very last
thing I'd do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
erly your hub for Home Services most
American homes have dozens of appliances
and chances are at any given time
there's something wrong with at least
one of them Mr Appliance a neighborly
brand offers expert appliance service on
your schedule visit neighborly.com to
find Home Service Experts including a Mr
Appliance in your area today's question
comes from Jonathan in Florida
I am 35 and my wife just had our first
baby I have roughly forty three thousand
dollars in debt my annual income is
around 73 000 I'm wanting to start my
baby steps but I had a quick question
about baby step one and two I have a
credit card that is maxed out at the
thousand dollar limit if I pay that card
off can I count that as I baby step one
and then tackle my snowball while
simultaneously putting a thousand
dollars cash in my savings account
no John it is so convoluted
no no no no
no because no a maxed out credit card
for a thousand dollars is not considered
your emergency fund your emergency fund
is considered cash that you have saved
so your own money so before you pay off
your credit card you save a thousand
dollars cash then you start working to
pay off your debts and this might be the
first one you pay off
appreciate Jonathan's you know if I have
a thousand dollar limit can I just cash
out a thousand dollars put that and then
the underlying bull crap in this
question is that he's going to use his
credit card as his emergency
he's going to use a stupid credit card
so that's the underlying bull crap yeah
that's just no sorry Jonathan
wish it was that easy you know Sharon
Rachel's mom when I'm when I do crap
like this Jonathan she goes you're
scheming and scamming again you're
trying to find a shortcut quit scheming
and scamming just do the work boy that's
Sharon that's Rachel's mom that's that's
that's what I get so yeah Jonathan just
you're scheming and scamming Jonathan
just do the work boy I mean oh my gosh
that's it yeah quit you cannot scam your
way into wealth okay you can't even
trick yourself into it and uh so no
we're not going to go a thousand dollars
in credit card debt for the emergency
fund but we appreciate the question so
cute here's a more sophisticated problem
so this was sent to me via Instagram
appreciate all my Instagram people there
uh because they will send me things a
lot and they're like oh my gosh what do
you think about this or what do you
think about that and this one came no
people might send me stuff too but I
don't look at it so I wouldn't know
you have to you like read the messages
or something is that what you're
supposed to do I am part of the people
these are my people so yes I get on into
people on social media you could too
social media that's how it works they're
real people out there on the other side
I know that enjoy your stuff you should
get in I love them so much I'm not gonna
get on it should go and talk to them
anyway and they sent you this yes and I
read the messages because I read my
messages and they're like hey I want you
and Dave talk about it and I was like oh
well perfect we'll be on the show
together so this was from a New York
Times article and the headline was I've
hidden my trust fund for 15 years do I
finally tell my spouse so you ready for
this I'm a 44 year old man and I've been
married to my spouse for 10 years we've
been together for 15. unbeknown to my
spouse I have a trust fund that provides
me with a monthly income of twenty five
thousand dollars when we first met I
said that I worked as a consultant and
they've never questioned it my spouse a
dedicated doctor Works long hours and
doesn't like to discuss work when not on
the job over the years I have repeatedly
assured my spouse that they don't need
to work as my income is secure and
stable they are however passionate about
their career and have chosen continue
working I actively serve on various
boards but I have never held a full-time
job and don't plan to our lifestyle is
Comfortably upper middle class and I'm
content with that my dilemma is whether
I should reveal the truth about my trust
fund to my spouse my family members have
always advised against disclosing our
financial situation but the weight of
the secret is becoming too difficult to
bear what do you do all day
he sits on boards oh somebody said I
don't know
um Place Wordle I wonder how often like
this kind of well we well we know that
spouses hide things from one another
that's a that's a consistent theme
through life like that's a known thing
um but this one was just interesting
because I'm like okay 25 Grand a month I
wonder what she thinks that he does
to earn that
amount of money I don't know so anyways
um what I would tell the name is
withheld they did not disclose the name
of the New York Times article
so yes if anyone out there has this
dilemma no or no one else or the idea
that you have a secret that is too
unbearable to bear that is from your
spouse listen we always teach and talk
about and believe that being on the same
page with your spouse is much better so
coming clean and telling them
anything and everything when it comes to
money anything you are withholding is
not only gonna just lift the weight off
your shoulders that you've been carrying
around having to navigate because I
think about this situation which this is
kind of is true I know it's a little
absurd but if you do think about it I'm
like the amount of like probably lies
and deception that had to have occurred
to cover the big to cover the big lie
that's a lot of work in life and I don't
know who has time for that so I'm just
like Free Yourself learning an awful lot
of calories free yourself being a liar
and you've been with your spouse for two
I mean like I mean I think it's fine and
then you know what she probably still
wants to be a doctor because she's
passionate about her work and that's
great
but yeah being upfront honest disclosing
everything
regardless of whether it's a 25 000
trust fund or it's a secret credit card
that you have whatever it is uh you and
your spouse be on the same page is is
crucial to to winning winning long term
yeah so
um yeah you should have disclosed this
day one and you should be continually
you should not have any secrets from
your spouse hello
period
I mean that's just a thing okay you just
cannot build a quality relationship
on Deception
duh okay so your family is screwed up
dude
because your family is telling you that
your money
and you're not needing to work
is is you how they know your secret and
your own freaking wife does not
and your family thinks that's good your
family's screwed up and then they left
you money so you don't have to work
that's screwed up
so let me tell you if you're going to
participate in the Ramsay trust it
involves continually working
because working is good for the soul
like real work yeah doing work showing
up and doing stuff you know this is not
good this is not healthy there's nothing
in this it's fun or it's only twenty
five thousand dollars only three hundred
thousand dollars a year it's not like
you're freaking rich I mean it's 300
Grand jeez no I mean really
no I mean it's not it's not three
million it's 300 000. and what does this
guy not done with his life that he
should have done pretty good I I agree
he should have done something with his
life instead he's the king of words I
mean oh my God I mean no really I mean
he's sitting on boards that's code for I
don't do much I'm telling you serious
this is wrong it's wrong
it's deception and it's all glassed over
as if my family has said we should not
share our money information because your
family thinks this money is a bigger
deal than it is it's just something more
important than your spouse yeah and more
important than your integrity in your
marriage yeah yeah you've been living a
long time in the in the super deception
and it's it's poisoned you man really
the cleanest best thing you can do
you'll be like an alcoholic who sits
down the bottle when you quit lying
you're gonna have a cleanliness of Soul
that's going to be so good for you and
is she going to be pissed well yeah of
course she's gonna be pissed she's been
lied to for 50 years jeez so yeah ah
yeah yeah of course she's gonna be mad
yeah I mean she if she's not she's a
wuss she should be mad this is just
nutty anger is a good thing yeah in that
situation I mean really you
but you're you're living a lie that's
why you had to put it out on the dad gum
ethicist columnist page you have to go
to ethics class to figure this one out
this is why we need ethics classes yeah
son uh don't and and papa don't do this
to your kids
you better off teach them how to work
and give them no money than give them
this crap this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ashley's in Nashville hi Ashley how are
you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um so I just wanted to get your
skin I have a friend that does your
house program as well as I've been doing
it since 2020 I'm still in babysit too
and we discussed it a few times but I'm
just not sure of my decision so in 2019
we adopted our son
and then a year later our marriage fell
apart and we split up so fast forward to
now
um well we've been to court two times
over custody issues
a lot of nonsense really his dad's just
really hard to get along with
um so but in those two times it's cost
me around 20 to 25 000 in court
returning fees and everything else so
um I'm trying to
just gain some traction on
um
maybe preparing for that in the future
because I feel like it's not going away
and still being able to pay off my bed I
really just don't know what to do
I'm sorry Ashley
that's really yeah that's a that's a
really hard situation
um
how much how much money do you make a
year
um so I work as much overtime as I can
um I try to last year I made around 100
000 and then um this year is probably
going to be between 80 and 90. okay what
do you do
I'm a nurse yeah good for you
thank you uh how much how much debt in
general do you have
um all together is probably around 90
000 and it's a mixture of vehicles uh to
well my vehicle alone and then
um I have
some credit cards and a line of credit
at the bank
audio in your car
uh 25
all right so you have 90 000 in debt and
25 of its car and then how much of its
credit cards
um around nine thousand
okay so the rest of it is what
um I have a lot of credit which is
around 20 000 that I opened up to pay
for court fees
um
and
I'm not sure I can't think of anything
else so I might be wrong that's only 45
that's only 54
000.
another vehicle my name but I don't pay
for it so that's another 48 000 but
that's not mine it's one in the world
who what is that
it's his truck but he makes all the
payments on that it doesn't cost me
anything but we went in together to get
it so
so your name is on the is it on the deed
on the on the loan on the title of the
truck
yeah yeah
but the divorce decree gave him the
truck and you're supposed to pay it or
he's supposed to pay it
so that's not his no that's like my
fiance that I have now I'm sorry
oh you so you have a so you're you're
gonna get a truck for your fiance for
fifty thousand dollars
so we went in to get her I didn't
necessarily buy it for him and we it's
something that we just done together
if you needed you to co-sign it
no no he's I mean he's doing good with
his money you know he no he's not he
took out a 50 000 truck loan yeah
there's money
why are you on the loan
uh because I mean we're we're getting
married and
um I just I don't I don't know it was
when are you getting married
uh hopefully within the next year okay
in the in the whole story that you told
us
that has a lot of uh tragedy and sadness
this thing then jumps up as super stupid
and crazy
right like a 50 000 truck while you're
fighting and don't have the money to pay
and you have to take out a line of
credit
and and the best idea y'all got to go in
debt for 50 Grand on a truck while
you're trying to keep a dadgum child in
a custody battle on going with a crazy
ex
this truck is crazy
nuts crazy yeah
yeah
so um all right so you're getting
married when did you say
okay uh
uh why are you waiting
um honestly because everything's just
been so crazy with my ex for the past
two years and I've dealt with
um anxiety and depression
um my son has a lot of issues he was
born with
and none of that's changing in a year
I'm sorry none of that is changing in a
year
I know yeah and we just we just not
just anxiety and depression on my side
and my main focus being my son right
that's just not been at the top of the
list I guess okay you called and asked
us for help and we love you and we want
you to win and we're sad that you're
having to fight to keep your baby okay
now then I'm going to tell you some hard
stuff are you okay with that
yes okay sell the stupid truck
get married
now
or don't
but don't wait around on some mythical
Island to Come Sailing up some mythical
ship to Come Sailing up to your Island
when everything's going to be right
because the things you've been facing
part of your anxiety and part of the
things you've been facing with mental
health stuff is not just your ex it's
this pile of stuff on you and all of
these un uh
untied knots knots that need to be tied
okay right you don't have closure on
anything all these open-ended things or
there's open ended this open-ended that
open into this there's no closure
anywhere and that creates angst it
creates anxiety so um yeah you've got to
get some some predictable order not
chaos to the more areas of your life you
can get non-chaos in the the faster your
anxiety is going to drop I'm not a
mental health professional Dr John
delonius I've just heard him say that so
I said it okay but that's the truth okay
so and these you know and the debt and
the pile of debt you guys have you have
and now you guys with this fifty
thousand dollar truck is part of where
your anxiety is coming from because you
don't you feel trapped and now you're
you're worried about the next time the
crazy ex comes at you how are we going
to cover that meantime I got a 48 000
truck note
okay and I know he takes care of it
Ashley but the truth is though if he
doesn't it's on you then and so you're
carrying this around your neck you feel
it in your between your shoulder blades
you feel the weight of it and that's
part of the anxiety you can't keep from
doing that by the way it's just how your
body and your mind and your spirit works
so yeah if I if you're my little sister
or my daughter I would tell you get
married
and sell the truck by the weekend
or run this guy off and sell the truck
by the weekend but painter get off the
ladder
right okay that's what I would tell you
to do if I loved you and I do so I want
you to do that okay and then we want you
to uh take this wonderful income you
have and you have a fabulous career
choice because you'll always have a job
and you can always make money when
you're a nurse it's just a great job and
actually I would sell your car honestly
I would get any level of attraction for
25 000 I'm like you can get a used ten
thousand dollar whatever it is but just
I would I would get out of that how hard
would you work how crazy would you go to
have twenty thousand dollars in the bank
and no debt so next time crazy X comes
around you can punch him in the nose
with a lawyer
right
well that's what I thought I was doing
this last time exactly and now but you
didn't you went over the car lot with
your goober fiance and bought a truck
okay so you went the other way so I want
you to sell everything in sight work
like crazy people live on beans and rice
rice and beans get married and let's get
the credit card debt paid off I mean all
of it yeah start getting some traction
with that debt payoff Ashley and I think
you're going to start to feel more in
control because you are that's why
you'll feel that way because you're
going to run the chaos off and drive
order in and and build a build a build a
war chest to go to war
and then you can fight for this baby
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show but we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author co-host of the smart
money Happy Hour podcast on the Ramsey
networks with old George camel is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sarah starts this hour in New York City
hi Sarah how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
start baby
custodial accounts and I didn't know if
I was supposed to use that on that I've
read make a Total Money Makeover in the
handbook and I just it wasn't clear so I
just wanted to clarify
uh I would not unless it was on some
kind of some kind of super emergency
technically technically you can
um but what what ends up happening is
most of us that are parents uh feel like
a dirt bag if we use kid money that we
set aside for our kid right
and that dirt bag feeling offsets any of
the good progress you're making
100 and I thought that's what you would
say but I just wanted to make sure yeah
how much debt have you got Sarah
um non-house related 74. okay and
household income's what
uh three times oh okay so you're gonna
be able to get it without doing the show
no trouble oh yeah for sure I think I
could probably do it in like 14 months
yeah um but how much is in the
custodials
oh it's not much it's like 10K yeah so
it doesn't even make a difference really
yeah it's just more more of a concept
than anything so yeah yeah yet another
reason but I mean if um
you know you're I don't know some
bizarre thing you had a medical
emergency or of a with an adult and like
you or your husband or something in the
house and you there's a hundred thousand
dollars in the kids account and we
needed to pay medical yeah I would use
it for that yeah you know but but but
um most of the time you just the the
negative feelings aren't uh don't uh you
know would offset any good the money
would do uh in my opinion and so that's
why we'd say don't do that I'd leave
that money alone what do you think yeah
that's what I was gonna say I was
curious the numbers or what it was
specifically for or where did they get
it if it was
that they funded it as parents yeah I
was just curious more of that
um but when it comes down to it yeah
that's exactly right it's their money so
I would stop adding until I'm debt free
and I would stop adding until I had my
emergency fund and I would stop adding
to a custodial until I had 15 baby step
four going into my uh into my retirement
fund so now so once you've walked up the
baby steps and you're back to baby step
five then you would start adding again
but I wouldn't um but it's kind of like
retirement in the sense I wouldn't Cash
Out retirement but I would stop adding
to it while you're at this stage Ben is
in Nashville hi Ben how are you
I'm doing okay how about yourself Dave
better than we deserve what's up
yeah so I have a question about
disability insurance my wife and I
it's a workplace my 60 uh and my wife is
70. and we have been considering getting
supplemental disability coverage we
don't have kids yet but plan on it
um and then next year 18 months and so
we were just wondering what your advice
would be on the supplemental coverage
generally it falls in the gimmick
category
um and and so the bang for the buck is
not as good uh is your workplace furnish
the other two disability policies
they furnished the the two that we have
right now we would be going outside
yeah I understand so uh and and so but
if you like
uh
your policy would cost prop would cost
your employer probably uh half what you
would pay for a small supplement policy
it's just it's not meaning the
supplement policies are expensive
they're a little bit gimmicky that's
what I'm saying for the actual coverage
they are expensive yeah and so
um I mean it's certainly dependent upon
your uh your occupation yeah and say
what do you all do Ben do you have a
high risk of something happening
physically to you because of a job or no
I'm a lawyer and my wife as a nurse
okay okay and uh what you are you guys
out of debt you've got some money built
up or what
we are on baby step number two right now
we should be out of out of debt and here
in about 16 months or so
um
and we make at 130 000 a year total okay
yeah I would not buy it
I would not buy supplemental in your
case I I as you've discovered it's not
it's expensive for what it what you get
and you know the you've got the main
thing covered because after taxes you're
you're 60 or your 70 is going to be
about what you're coming home I mean
you're coming home with 80 probably but
I mean you're you're not gonna lose
uh you're not gonna be living on 60 of
your current take-home you're me leaving
60 of your gross or 70 of your gross and
so
um yeah and
he if I woke up in your shoes when I was
in your shoes I did not carry additional
disability and um but I will reiterate
because I'm glad you brought this up
it's not something we talk about enough
on this
long-term disability insurance is the
most under insured area
in America you need long-term disability
insurance hopefully you can buy it
through work very inexpensively or work
furnishes it for you or you can buy it
through your Association if you're a
home builder and you buy through the
Home Builders Association or whatever
something like that but get long-term
disability insurance it is very
inexpensive for what it is for that
first 60 to 70 percent amount and you're
32 times more likely to become disabled
than to die
if you're 30 years old between 30 and 65
so your probability of disability
between 30 and 65 is high much higher
than it is if you uh than death is and
yet we all run around talking about life
insurance and you need to get life
insurance too but um but yeah so Ben
brings up a really valid point that
disability insurance is vital but
supplemental is not yeah so for any
additional does
Insurance when would be a time that
you're like yeah I would recommend
something I mean is it is it labor
because I would think if you're at a job
that is more physically taxi like you
know I mean if there's if you're in a
blue collar situation of some kind yeah
your your Disability Policy is going to
be even higher because it's as much
occupation based as it is age or
health-based so anything X -rays
high-rise window cleaner right right
versus you drive a cubicle for a living
right you know it's a whole different
set of categories for you to get uh
they're gonna it's really expensive okay
so again you've got to go back and try
to get it through some kind of an
association but you know what we're
talking about is something like an Aflac
policy and it's like the cancer policy
The Accidental deaths yeah yeah the cat
Insurance the uh heart attack Insurance
whatever all this it's all gimmick stuff
yeah and so I don't I don't spend money
on that stuff at all and so I'm sorry
Nick Saban but I just don't there you go
this you're not sorry sorry not sorry
Aflac duck yeah but there we go this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so before we went on the air today you
did your uh free webinar on budgeting
with every dollar gang right yes we did
yep we had
um yeah a couple thousands show up I
think over ten eleven thousand
registered so there'll be some replays
going out to those people that submitted
their email address but um but yeah it
went really well we kind of just dove
into the fact that your budget really is
the found one of the foundational
principles of winning long term you do
this in baby step one all the way to
seven and how most people feel still
just out of control with their money
that paycheck to paycheck cycle and then
you have inflation on top of that
student loan payments are about to start
coming in again so so there's just a lot
there so really pressing people and
showing them hey here's how to do a
budget and then even with every dollar
every dollar premium like here's the
here is the functions for your
day-to-day life with money and how we
built it to help people again day to day
having it accessible on your phone uh
and just making it something that's part
of your your habits on an everyday basis
so it was uh it was great and I have
another one on the 24th of August
um so you can sign up at everydollar.com
com webinar for that one and
everydollar.com budgeting well I think
that one's Jade's I think we all have
different no it's every they're all
known they're now they're all on
according to this thing I have in my
hand okay well according to the website
okay I could be wrong but anyway so
anyway you can try either one
everydollar.com budgeting Jay it'll be
teaching another one she had ten
thousand at hers George's uh George is
doing one as well coming up soon too
August 30th is Jade and George and
Rachel Cruz all of these are free
webinars on budgeting with the student
loans bearing down on you inflation
bearing down on you credit card debts at
an all-time high uh folks are needing to
get control and the budget's a tool that
helps you do that it's completely free
to go to one of these webinars so go to
everydollar.com budgeting or
everydollar.com webinar was my last
webinar they made changes since let's
see what it is so you can find it either
way we'll get you going yeah open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Julie is with us in Houston
Texas hi Julie how are you
hi I'm fine and you better than I
deserve what's up
well um my husband's family has a
history of very the early onset
Alzheimer's my husband had to stop
working at 49 years old so he has it
right right he does and his mom had it
and she had to stop working like early
50s and she lived to be 67. now I say
that so you understand that maybe with
the early onset they live a lot longer
right needing care a lot longer and I
have three kids and so um
they are in their 20s 29 26 24 and so
they have about 15 to 20 years to
prepare financially for the possibility
of them needing 15 years of care and I
don't want them to be in the same mess
that you know my husband and I are in so
my question to you is how can they
prepare financially
for this huge
um
burden now I know they need long-term
care insurance but they're going to need
you know a substantial amount of money
as well yeah
I'm sorry wow what a tough thing you
guys are going through
um yeah how long was he diagnosed Julie
your husband
um five years 54 now how's he doing
well he's attending an adult day care
and he's starting to progress a little
bit
um starting with hallucinations and
stuff and
just yeah he's painting on me I'm so
sorry Julie
[Music]
uh
well there's no there is no uh
different formula it's just um
it's just got this uh
I don't know a different urgency I guess
if you will uh to prepare because as you
said long-term care insurance the
typical policy only covers three or four
years
um most of them don't cover you know
from 49 to 65 kind of thing you can
investigate those types of policies the
ones that I have seen are very expensive
they're inordinately expensive because
the uh the long-term care industry is
figured out that not counting you know
you're obviously you all are an outlier
statistically but the typical nursing
home stay is three years or less two and
a half to three years that's the average
uh and so they're covering that and
that's about all they're covering so
they're not
um but yeah you can investigate that and
the first three to four years of use of
the policy then when you are not able to
care for them care for someone you know
you would do that uh and but other than
that it's a it's a wealth building
formula what's the best wealth building
formula you know walking these baby
steps and Building Wealth now
you know you may want to adjust your
baby step four and start thinking like
it like sometimes people call us and
they're going to retire early before 59
and a half and to have access to their
401ks and Roth IRAs and so forth which
you can get hardship access to those
without penalties but uh it's hard to
prove it and hard to pull it off so if
but if someone's going to retire early
we tell them put some of their money in
non-retirement investing call Bridge
investing
and so you know instead of putting 15
all into Roth IRAs and 401ks I might put
10 there and five percent into just S P
500 or some mutual funds that have low
turnover ratios right so that you've got
some money that's not trapped in a 401k
that you could get to in case you had
the deal this with this before 59 and a
half does that make sense
and most likely they will yeah yeah if
uh if they yeah if you know face the
same thing more of them probably it's
not yeah it's not a hundred percent but
yeah you've had this had this horrible
pattern that you guys have watched
um and yeah very very tough so yeah
um
you know and and then I guess the rest
of the equation is spiritual and
emotional isn't it
yes you know just just walking uh
through something like this in in as a
faith exercise so to speak and then and
dealing with the emotions of what you
guys are facing I'm so sorry I wish I
had I wish I had a really good easy
answer to make the the money part easy
and even but even the money part's not
going to be easy yeah and I think Julie
for them just to be able to which I'm
sure they are because they're
experiencing with their dad I mean as we
speak and so
um for them to know hey I I have to be
even more disciplined and buckled down
um knowing you know some things about my
future that is a possibility you know
unlike the average person's walk around
they and they don't know you know they
may not have that deep of a family
history that they are aware of so it
kind of just fast forwards for them
a level of I mean kind of buckling down
and maturity to know okay if this is
really true how much do I need to have
so my family can take care of me and
that may mean sacrificing you know
some of the fun or whatever it may be
but just being that much more
intentional and then also I think having
the joy of life and that was the
emotional spiritual part that you were
kind of talking about but also not
letting fear
um you know drive drive all of this you
know John delone is coming out with a
new book
um called building a non-anxious life
and not that that book is going to have
all the answers
um Julie for your situation but stay on
the line and Austin can pick up because
we want to give you it's on pre-order
right now but we'll get you uh set up
for for that to ship to you and then
anyone else listening because I think
that that's um it's a part of this
equation that it could so easily turn
into Madrid a lot yeah which is
reasonable and understandable but also
you don't want it to steal
um the the parts of life that do have
the joy and being able to live in that
but that's so difficult exactly
so sorry you're facing that and if we
can help you any any way as you're
walking through this you call us anytime
we'll help you any way we can but um
yeah the idea that um oh I'll deal with
that later I'm just going to screw
around now in my 20s and be
irresponsible those kids don't have that
option yeah they got to lean in they
gotta they gotta be serious from day one
and
that that's not a bad thing that part
that part's not a bad thing the reason
is a bad thing but the result is not a
bad thing this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Danielle is in St Louis hi Danielle how
are you
hi I'm doing well how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up
good hey
um I have a car fleece right now and it
is going to end in April the end of
April 2024 and I'm starting to prepare
what I need to be doing at the end of
that
um currently I'm in baby step two I
started last June and I've I'm about at
the halfway mark right now but I'm
wondering the only thing I have left in
my snowball is three student loans and
then of course I'm just making my normal
monthly payments on my car
so I don't know if I should be trying to
put aside money to buy that out at the
end the value on it versus what I will
have to pay for the buyout is about 6
000 in equity that I should have so I
don't know if I should be setting aside
money do you think you're going to be
able to buy it six thousand dollars
cheaper than it's worth yes I mean right
now
it's very unusual
I just looked at the KBB today and it's
valuing at about twenty six thousand
um in my buy outfit the online actual
lease contract has it at twenty twenty
thousand six hundred and forty two
dollars in April
in April yeah
in April right
probably six thousand dollars is it I
don't know I mean what kind of car is
this
um it's a Subaru Crosstrek and I'm
significantly under my mileage as well
so part of me is like you don't get
credit for that but the only way you get
credit is the actual value of the car so
I'm gonna guess and say the car is going
to be worth 22. okay I'll just make a
number up okay okay and you can buy it
for 20 and so you're not overpaying for
the car but you've got all these student
loan debts and you got twenty thousand
dollar car uh and you're under your
mileage uh what's your household income
it's just me
just me my
before I'm estimating to make about 12
this year so about 62 give or Shake
and what is left in your debt snowball
just three student loans
three student loans and then just my my
fleece payments what's the balance on
the student loans each
I have I just made a payment today so
it'll be thirty five hundred
seven thousand three hundred and eight
thousand nine hundred so total will be
nineteen seven okay
all right uh I have a theory of what I
might do sure
um I'm all open ears yeah I don't think
you're gonna have twenty thousand
dollars and be debt free by April unless
there's some kind of Miracle happens in
the numbers I didn't hear okay so if you
were dead free and you had twenty
thousand dollars cash and you wanted to
buy the car we can talk about that but
uh if you were going to just walk up and
buy a 20 000 car in the middle of what
you're going through right now you
wouldn't
yeah that's fair you know and so
that means you don't buy this twenty
thousand dollar car and because it's not
going to be worth 26 in April it's gonna
be worth 21 22 it's not it's not going
to be the deal of the century at least
it's just not going to be there so I'm
turning it in and I'm gonna have saved
five thousand dollars to pay cash for a
car
and so I'm gonna I'm Gonna Knock Out the
35 I'm Gonna Knock Out the 3500 and then
I'm Gonna Save five thousand dollars so
I'm putting five thousand dollars in
your debt snowball to buy a car
okay and I do I have been putting a
little bit aside already so I'm at about
six so then I could consider that done
oh you were already cheating the baby
steps I I don't know that I call it
cheating I call it preparing that it's
coming
oh okay all right well I would stop uh
and buy a six thousand dollar car
and uh when and when April gets here and
in the meantime I would just tear into
these student loans and then you can
move back up in car later uh with cash
after you get your emergency fund in
place but
in other words if this car was ten
thousand dollars to buy instead of 20 we
might stretch and do it but 20 is a bit
of a stretch with your income numbers
because you're only dealing with 62.
that's kind of what I mean what I mean I
was like
I did right right around the
questionable Mark yeah it's a little
above the bubble for me to be wanting to
do it if if I'm in your shoes I'm just
saying what would I do if I woke up in
your shoes so and except for the six
thousand dollar already saved part yeah
yeah you were right on we were right
there together yeah she's doing it
before you even told her now some people
might be like but Dave you're going off
the baby steps you're going after that
snowball but this would be a time to say
I'm selling a car
so let's it would be like if you're
selling it would be the same as if you
had a 35 000 car loan and we're like hey
sell it and get a chance yeah yeah yeah
and let's say you were upside down on a
car and take a loan out and you ended up
with a small loan those are the baby
steps that's the same thing too so all
of this is just we've got to get we got
to provide for basic Transportation yep
and so yeah six thousand dollar car fits
beautifully in this and she's already a
step ahead of us bill in New York City
hi Bill how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I am in between buying an apartment for
myself and buying a mixed-used building
and I'm not sure what to do
hmm
well both are excellent things
and so it's a choice between excellent
things right
it's not like I don't know I don't think
one's in the stupid column and one's not
okay the advantages in
a 20-year game plan
of owning the home you live in are
pretty dramatic
um and but but obviously investment real
estate is pretty dramatic and wonderful
so uh
but what happens is what people don't
think about when you buy a home the
first thing you do is you do away with
rent and rent goes up every year
and home you know what you pay for your
home doesn't go up every year or go up
some with taxes insurance but I'm
talking about your payment the the
largest line item in your budget is
locked in the second thing is it's going
up in value tax free 250 000 can be
profit uh after one year held a single
500 000 married
and then the third thing is is the one
of the things we find in the millionaire
studies studying millionaires is one of
the biggest items is a paid for home
that uh stabilizes your uh you know your
your last 30 years of your life you
don't have increasing rents and you've
got a very stable predictable
non-chaotic situation because your home
life is steady versus investment real
estate over there is playing Monopoly
yeah and that's more of a game yeah yeah
so I mean I think owning your own
place of residence is it's a huge factor
in not only just Building Wealth but if
your entire just Financial picture for
not just the Math's sake but also just
the Peace of mind's sake of having a
place to live that's yours and again the
fact that it's going up in value and all
of that is is fantastic so
um so yeah I'm all about buying a home
for myself but also investing in real
estate it's it's another great option
for for wealth building too yeah yeah if
I were you I would buy a house first
that's what I'm trying to say you know
after all that babbling that's what I
was saying you know so yeah just
straight up by a home and uh didn't get
it paid for and then save up and pay
cash for investment real estate and uh
Rachel's husband Winston runs our family
real estate and he's a real estate
investor as well they always pay cash we
pay cash
um for investment real estate we love
real estate I'm a huge real estate fan
but I'm not a huge mortgage fan and I
just there's
uh
I can always relate I don't know it's
one part uh it's a you know it's a 42
years I've been married almost 41 years
I've been married and
um in my 42nd year I guess is the way of
saying it and yet I can still remember
that part of being single that I think
gosh I could live in a tent and have
investment real estate you know because
I always wanted to be an investor that
badly I've always wanted to buy real
estate and so you know that's kind of
what he's thinking he's thinking I just
that that apartment over there owning
that thing will be so cool and so I can
always relate to that emotionally that's
what causes me to babble through the
answer but at the end of the Babbling I
still bought a house this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Savannah's in
Orlando hi Savannah welcome to the
Ramsay show
Hi how are you better than we deserve
what's up
owners and and our property taxes car
insurance rates in Florida went up like
crazy this past year we are under on a
lot of our bills and we've been trying
to make it work with our savings our
savings are running out in the next few
months and we're trying to decide if we
should sell our home because we have a
lot of equity in the home or if we
should accept a ten thousand dollar gift
from a family member to help us be able
to stay in the home a little longer
okay so Savannah how much how much is
your home worth
um a realtor came and they said our home
was worth about 400 000 and how much do
you owe on it
um I believe uh we got it two years ago
it was 251.
um I'm sorry I'm blanking how much we
owe on it still
um they said we'd walk away with
um a hundred and thirty thousand roughly
if we got for what it was worth
how much do you own your car
um our cars are a big issue we pay
um all our debt we owe about 25
um for our debt
what do you owe on your car
um my car is I believe 16 000 and my
husband's is 5 000.
what's your household income
um we bring home about 3 900 a month
okay what are you gonna do on the ten
thousand dollar gift Runs Out
that's why I was thinking maybe selling
the home was would be better but I
wasn't sure
what what we should do I wanted to make
the right choice
[Music]
well the fact that the 10 000 gift is a
is a it's just Financial denial
I mean you're just kicking the can down
the road you still haven't dealt with a
problem
the problem is your budget's upside down
okay right that's kind of what you were
already thinking yeah you were already
thinking that so what's your household
income again
3 900.
a month
um oh I'm sorry a month
four thousand dollars a month how much
is your house payment
um it went up to 1700 a month yeah I saw
your house
okay you can afford the house and it
wasn't the insurance you couldn't afford
it before
and you may need to sell the sixteen
thousand dollar car too
okay y'all are swimming in stress aren't
you
yes we are this is not fun are y'all
fighting
no we're we're handling
it pretty well while we're trying to
trust the Lord and decide what to do
action for I'm fighting
oh yeah
I'm kidding with you all right so how
long you guys been married how long you
been married
three years okay and you've been
collecting crap the whole time you got
married now you got a big old pile of
crap and a big old pile of debt so let's
get rid of a bunch of crap and get your
life back
sell The Sixteen thousand dollar car
sell the house and get your life back I
want you to like your life in each other
again yeah and there's a part of
trusting the Lord absolutely we're
people of Faith but there's also that
Savannah you guys have to do you you
guys have to make decisions hard
decisions and you have to put action
towards things that are needed right do
you get that too like if I weigh 300
pounds and I want to lose weight I can't
just trust the Lord I have to back off
the donuts
right there's both things right and that
that's the thing and that that's like
Dave's example because Dave's addicted
to Donuts so uh although I have I'm
donut free for gosh about almost three
years now I'm donut-free so you bring
down a star house pretty good I'm gonna
get my little donut coin soon oh my gosh
but um yeah
um but yeah Savannah I mean and I think
for you guys honestly
um if you stay on the line Austin's
gonna pick up because I want you guys
you and your husband you've been married
three years to go through Financial
Peace University this is nine lessons on
exactly step by step what to do with
your money because you guys are just
kind of
you're just you're just normal I mean
really is what it comes down to you're
like you have a great house you have
great cars and you think oh God everyone
else seems to be getting ahead and doing
well and here I am and this there's a
lot of stress to this life that looks
like it should be okay and it's not and
I don't know what we're doing wrong and
so having a very methodical plan where
you guys are on the same page and you
know what's going on and you actually
have a plan that you're working towards
and that's probably going to mean
selling the house
um that's going to mean selling the car
that's being backing off on some stuff
because yeah I mean you guys are you
know I mean after taxes you're probably
bringing home 40K
um so that's what you have to work with
and there's a lot of deck here compared
to that income and so it's probably does
feel very overwhelming but it's possible
to to change all of this but it's going
to require a lot of sacrifice and
diligence on you guys on your ends and
you can do that if you'll take a machete
to some of this junk in your life you'll
um you'll get a life back because right
now you don't even realize how how hard
it is to breathe yeah because you're
just you're concentrating and you're
being sweet and honestly you called with
the exact right question and you already
knew the answer to it that the ten
thousand dollars just kicks the can down
the road it's you're living in an
unsustainable set of mathematics
and the mathematics are kicking your
butt and you you already knew that so
you're you're on top of it you're gonna
you got the stuff to win Rachel's right
we'll get you signed up for Financial
Peace University you know her case is
almost like a stereotypical case study
thing Larry Burkett used to say we
uh spend the first seven years of our
marriage trying to attain the same
standard of living as our parents
but it took them 35 or 40 years to get
there yeah and we do it in four or five
years of marriage they've been married
three years four years and they just
been get a house get cars get a house
get cars get ready baby and you just
gather and then you all of a sudden you
look up and you go oh crap I can't
breathe oh I'm gonna kill you the
stressor I'm gonna kill my spouse my
stresses level is so high and so you
know and but that's the the problem is
the stupid banks will loan you so much
money that they put you in bankruptcy
because they don't have an off button
they'll just loan you money you know you
can go get a credit card you can go on a
trip you can't afford you can go you go
down there and get a car and I'm like
you know I was sitting with a young
couple when I first started doing
coaching many years ago
their take-home pay was 2 600 bucks and
the guy had a 1200 car payment
which was a that's insane for it now
saying 30 years ago that was yeah that
would be like having a 3 000 or 2500 car
payment now right but he you know 2600
our take home paid 1200 car payment yeah
and he's like we're having trouble
paying for our kids food and I'm like
well no kidding I said you need to sell
a stupid car man and he's like no
um
I can't sell the car I said yes you can
because no God gave us that car I said
God did not give you that car
he goes how you know I said because the
scripture is real clear the blessings of
the Lord have no sorrow added to them
and this has got sorrow written all over
it Bubba and he goes well even the
finance manager said it was a miracle
[Laughter]
I've been I bet it was a dead come
miracle that some Bank approved your
crazy butt little purchase but they will
they will loan you so much that even the
finance manager thinks it's a miracle
can't believe it went through it must be
the Lord wow I made another
Saleh thank you Lord oh my gosh the guy
in God's up there going I got nothing to
do with this don't blame this on me
don't put my name there
oh hey the banks will loan you so much
they just you know and you know there's
actually people out there walking around
that still think that if the bank will
loan it to you it means you can afford
it
but the same people that thinks if you
have checks left in your checkbook there
must be money in the account mm-hmm
people
well because you can afford the payment
you know what I mean like that's that's
the mindset I can afford the the living
situation that we're in because we're
not behind on payments and all of it
right so you're just staying right
afloat and that's where risk and life
and job loss and sickness all that never
comes into play but when it does then
that's your wake-up call gotta love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author co-host of the smart
money happy hour on the Ramsey networks
and also my daughter is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Todd starts this
hour in Phoenix hi Todd how are you
Rachel
hey Todd what's up
I'm just calling up to uh
ask uh how do I protect myself from an
inheriting a timeshare
and to add a little context to that
question
uh my in-laws they have expressed to my
wife and her siblings
that they plan on uh including the two
times shares and two they're both and
trust and
pretty much I want to make sure that
that times there has no way it ever
getting to to my wife and I and
our siblings have also expressed their
their
uh they they don't want to to inherit
the time shares either so
um is there anything that we do my wife
and I too so the kids have figured out
that Time Shares are basically legalized
fraud one of the worst products on the
planet but the parents hadn't figured
this out yet
they you know they they love it they
they they think it's the best thing it's
like so what I just said you you guys
hate it they love it the parents still
haven't figured it out okay so basically
a timeshare is a liability
it's a bill it's a problem which you
what you're saying and I don't want to
inherit a bill well you don't inherit a
bill so you're not going to end up
owning this it's not going to be
transferred to your name under any
circumstances because you won't sign the
transfer papers
you're just going to give them the old
uh salute no thank you
right
now now could the time sir company
foreclose on the timeshare and they can
come back against the estate but they
cannot come back against you
so they may take some of the parents
assets
likely will likely will screw up the
estate but it's not going to come
against you it might come against what
your wife would have inherited from her
parents
it might mess that up but it's not going
to mess you you and your wife up because
you're not liable for your for your
in-laws stupidity
does that make sense
so they're what they're doing is they're
poisoning their inheritance
would there ever be a crusation with you
guys
yeah we I mean do they know that you
guys don't want it
yeah so so my wife and her siblings they
have had that conversation and
um but you know we we've all I guess
benefited from the time shares they you
know they like I said they love their
points they they use them
and uh you know they they provided you
know room accommodations for us on trips
and stuff but you know when time comes I
mean if you buy a hotel if you're great
if your mother-in-law buys your hotel
room it's the same thing
except she doesn't end up damaging her
estate later
yeah so yeah I think you guys need to
explain to them that this is going to
mess up their estate
yeah all right well this is good news
knowing that it can't ever come to my
wife and myself no you can't because you
you do not inherit debt
but the uh and this is Dad it's a bill
it's a liability but you but but the
estate does have to stand good for the
estate so anything that they own stands
against anything they owe
but you do not inherit debt
that may not be an issue then because we
did it expressed to us that uh who will
the time shares will also receive a cash
account I guess loaded with 20 grand the
pay maintenance fees but no I don't want
to 20 grand I don't want the time share
keep the stupid thing throw it that's
right no no 20 grand won't even touch it
people pay 20 grand to get out of these
dad blame things
all the time I mean it's just it's a
horrible business
full of fraud full of scummy operators
it's a filthy business and yeah you
don't want anything to do with it no
under no circumstances are we taking
this timeshare you can't give us enough
money to take it it's like it's a poison
pill
all right so that's really yeah I was
just seeing if there's any other stuff
to protect myself so yeah you're fine
you you know how do I protect myself
from my mother-in-law going 80 000 in
credit card debt you don't have to
because you're not liable but you're not
going to get any inheritance because
when they sell the house they got to pay
the 80 000 in credit card debt before
you get anything what you own stands
against what you owe when you die but
children do not inherit debt it will
affect what they inherit
because the debt has to be paid before
there's any distribution net
of the debt and so the stupid timeshare
is a debt and it's an ugly debt because
it's very hard to get rid of you get
stuck in these things and one lawyer
calls it legalized fraud and again we've
worked with the timeshare industry they
are the filthiest nastiest lyingest
bunch of Thieves I've ever seen on the
planet they're horrible they feed on old
people they feed on dumb people they
just it's awful it's a whole they put
old people in buses and ship them over
there lock them in a room and keep
feeding them pretzels until they buy a
dadgum Timeshare it's awful they're
horrible business so have I been unclear
I was gonna say how do you feel how do I
really feel about time shares it's an
end man I'll tell you it is it's great
yeah you know
you know it's uh other Industries do do
bad things that are not good for you but
this industry is particularly scummy I
mean like the credit card people credit
cards are stupid but uh they're straight
up they just say you know it's 28 we're
going to screw you and you're gonna love
it and people just go take it and they
just you know sign their but they can
cut it up and get rid of it I mean at
least you could get away from that yes
yes I mean whole life people you know
we're going to take all your money and
give you almost no insurance and make
you act like and and somehow make you
think that that was a smart idea and
we're going to screw you and you're
gonna love it but at least you can
cancel the policy you know you know car
lease at least you can get out of a car
lease stinking timeshares man it's like
a oh yeah yeah sorry you just got me all
riled up Todd I hate these I hate that
well and they pray too on and old people
and dumb people well yeah yeah but they
they go and they target obviously
specific people that they see out at a
hotel and they're like hey we can rope
you in yeah and and knowing that they
probably don't even have the money to
pay for this stuff I mean like it's yeah
playing golf the other day down in dad
gum Cabo and this guy comes up and goes
hey you want your golf free and I'm like
yeah and he goes all you gotta do is sit
down oh get away from me
I'm gonna take a seven iron to your
house you should knowing that you're not
going to sign up for it around a golf
I'm gonna sit and listen to your crap
not a chance
unbelievable this is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host Teresa is in
Little Rock Arkansas hi Teresa how are
you
better than I deserve what's up well I
am knocking on the door of 61. I have no
retirement money saved up whatsoever
I've been working the baby steps I've
got my little thousand dollars
and
um hopefully Social Security will still
be there when I retired 67.
my question is even though I'm in the
baby steps to
my company uh matches four percent and
I'm just wondering if I should go ahead
and be putting that four percent into my
401k even though I'm still in baby step
two so you're 61 and have no money
none
what do you make
uh uh I bring home roughly 67 000. what
is your debt
a little over 69 000 on what
uh student loan is 11. I have a car loan
of 18.
I have a personal loan of 12 and then uh
I guess you could say another personal
loan of 26 on a tractor
why do you have a tractor
uh well we're country folks where's your
husband
my husband is 75 he's drawing Social
Security he is basically
um
disabled
I guess you could say he has COPD and
emphysema he's had three back surgeries
so he don't need to be on a tractor
who's the tractor not anymore broke
people don't have 26 000 tractors
well I have tried everything I can to
try and sell this thing other than just
letting it go back and
letting them sell it for whatever they
can sell it for
no you're paying the difference tractors
are selling right now what's what
contractor is this it's a Kubota
contractural cell
uh well you haven't tried to sell this
tractor I
am price of what my payoff on it is well
your payoff is a personal loan it's not
a try is it again yeah does it have an
actual lean on the tractor yes okay with
who who do you owe Kubota
uh yes okay
well I would go to the credit union and
borrow the five thousand dollars worth
of difference and get this tractor sold
and you need to sell your car too
you guys are in emergency mode girl
you don't buy 26 000 tractor when you're
broke
well this was two years ago before I
discovered Dave Ramsey this past March
what's your land worth
um
probably about
three or four thousand
your land is worth three thousand
dollars
yeah we
yeah we it it's we've
been an acre
no
for the whole seven acres
your 26 000 tractor for a four thousand
dollar piece of land
well we hunt and I use it to clear deer
leases and our hunting area and food
plots yeah I told you I was country girl
I'm not criticizing country I love
country I was over Bush Hogan last
weekend on my farm so I got that uh and
just because it's therapy but yeah but
okay uh I admit it was a stupid purchase
yeah it is yeah spur of the moment
purchase
it gives you Joy but not as much joy as
being as being broke is stealing from
you
right yeah and you're starting to look
up and go I need something to eat other
than social insecurity when I get to 66
67. so yeah yeah I if if I'm in your
mode I am so scared I'm going crazy and
I'm selling tractor I'm selling car I'm
gonna get a two thousand dollar car I'm
gonna work like a crazy person are you
leasing the land did you say dearly
hunting lease are you leasing it out to
people it did no no it's land that other
people own that has given us permission
uh to hunt we're not having that
physically pay for a lease oh you don't
have to pay a lease but you're not
receiving any lease money on your seven
acres
okay all right that's what I was trying
to get to okay
all right you have seven acres and
literally the only value of it is four
or five thousand dollars
500 bucks an acre is it Mountain Land or
something
no it's it it's just it's in between a
bunch of uh errors that and nobody
I mean it's paid for I know I know but
it's just hard for me to imagine land
that's that cheap 500 an acre land in
Arkansas
I mean you must be piping sunlight in
there okay we are all right we are all
right I got you girl only God knows
where we're at I love it I kind of think
I'm gonna like I think that I've got a
feeling it's beautiful I really do but
uh but anyway though okay so all right
um
Teresa why do you have a 11 000 student
loan
I've been paying on it since 1999.
and did not take advantage of paying the
last three years
okay so you've got to get in high gear
mode because if you'll get this mess
cleaned off you can you'll have plenty
of money to save and invest but you've
got so many payments coming out you
ain't got any room in your budget to
invest and that's why we tell people to
clean their debt before they take
advantage yeah so the short short answer
don't I want you to get free in a year
by selling everything in sight I want
your husband afraid he's going to be
sold next
okay and uh and uh you know and every
deer in the area needs to be afraid
you're going to sell him because you're
going to shoot him and put him on
something and sell him I mean oh my gosh
you're unbelievable you've got to
scratch up every dollar you can clean
everything up and and knock this out as
fast as you possibly can because you
don't have any money to invest you don't
have any room in your budget with what
you described to me so uh and you've you
got you know as you said you got six
years so we've got we got to make we got
to make hay while the sun shines and you
got to get with it and um
and Teresa it's gonna be it's going to
be extremely uncomfortable just know
that going in because it's going to be
really uncomfortable being 82 and she
wrote money 100 and a rusty track but
you're you know what I mean but I'm like
after Decades of living a certain way
untangling that
is much more difficult I think than when
you're living some some way for five
years and you're in you know I mean
you're you're taking a life Teresa and
you're turning on its head I mean you're
going to be doing some really yeah newer
ways of thinking that are going to feel
very uncomfortable but keep pressing
through even though it's hard and every
time every time you do something smart I
want you to say I'm doing this because
I'm a country girl I don't want you to
do anything else dumb and say I'm doing
this because I'm a country girl quit
blaming dumb stuff on country girl blame
smart stuff on country girl because
country girls do smart stuff
and and you know this is what that's
what you're about to do you're about to
do some really difficult things and
people in your life are gonna think
you've lost your dadgum mind but what
you're doing is you're trying to secure
a reasonable
last three decades two decades of your
life you know and and that that's very
important to fight for it's very
important to fight for and it's possible
Teresa we've talked to people it's
getable five years from down from where
you are
and it's a completely different
situation so you do you it's never too
late we always get that question is it
too late it's not too for me you know
and not too late but you're trading a 26
000 tractor for 150 000 bucks in your
retirement
you're trading at 18 000 car for another
hundred thousand dollars in your
retirement you could have a quarter of a
million dollars set aside with match if
you'll get your butt out of debt now by
the time you hit 67 68 years old you can
get there if not maybe maybe 200 maybe
not two and a quarter or maybe not 250
but you can get to where you don't have
this sense of being broke and then if
you want to go buy a six thousand dollar
tractor to play with out of your two
hundred thousand dollars and your
seventy fine go do that but otherwise
don't no no no and blame all smart
things on being a country girl don't
blame dumb things on being a country
girl this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in Maine is John Portland Maine to be
exact hey John how are you
Hi how are you better than we deserve
how can we help sir
yes uh so I have a question regarding my
40K of student loan debt once I pay off
roughly 15 000 of other debt do I make a
charge to pay off my 40K of student loan
debt or use a main tax credit program
that over 10 years would result in me
paying 5 000 the program would refund me
my payments on as a refundable tax
credit and should the program fall
through at some point in three years or
so down the road I plan to have the
money saved to pay the loans back
immediately so that I get rid of that
debt but is it a wise thing to just make
a charge at it disregard the program or
Let It Go the 10 years and pay the 5
000.
over 10 years pay it off John
yep disregard the program
um
for many different reasons but one of
them is just that you have the ability
to pay this off and you will be debt
free on your own regardless very quickly
regardless of a program or the
government's assistant whatever it is
like you you have the ability John to
pay this off and to be debt free and to
move on with your life if Maine had a
program that would give you five
thousand dollars in one year
while you're doing it anyway yeah we
would take it
but Maine has a program that keeps you
in debt for 10 freaking years
I'm not standing around in this sewage
for 10 years
no way yeah get your life back what do
you make
I make 65 000 at this point what do you
do look into I'm an electrical engineer
in the power industry
okay how long you been out of school
uh just a couple years I I did just
switch jobs right I took a little bit of
a pay decrease to just transition to a
better work culture as you definitely uh
elude on in your show yeah because
you're not making much for an electrical
engineer
that's why I'm kind of like whoa
yeah I know I had to take a bit of a pay
hit and transition to um a different
what other debts do you have John
uh my other debt is roughly 15K 12 000
in credit cards to get me through school
and then
um I have 2500 in personal loan yeah you
know most electrical engineers make like
a hundred right
yes uh and that's that's more you have a
couple years of more than a couple years
experience from five and
um maybe a PE two but
um I'm only a couple years out I would
like to see myself around 80. yeah I'm
making some changes to try to okay good
see if that can happen but all right I
just didn't want you to be settling down
there about 65 cents on the dollar where
you should be ending up so because you
got a great degree It's a Wonderful It's
a Wonderful degree that's right you got
a great choice by the way the number one
career field of people that become
millionaires in America is engineer
number two is accountant number three's
teacher just to kind of give you an idea
so that's uh of all I mean we did the
largest study a millionaires ever done
that's what we found so you're in a
great place that's why I'm rooting for
you I think you chose well there but
yeah let's get the debt cleared off as
fast as we can uh yeah and and the
opportunity cost on your life
what you could have been doing with your
life while you were screwing around for
10 years with the state of Maine is not
worth it
get get this stuff paid off yesterday
take six Jobs sell stuff get it cleared
up really really really fast and go have
you a wonderful life yeah and you know
the student loan conversation is is Big
because I think there's 40 million
Americans that student loan payments
will be hitting in October and it's
something that we're actually going to
address on our live stream on Tuesday
September 12th uh it'll be at 7 pm
central time it's free you guys so make
sure to tune in because this the student
loan there's so many of these types of
things of these programs and even with
you know everything that happened with
the Supreme Court I mean like there's
there's all this stuff there's all this
chatter yeah how did we get here where
do we go from here yeah and so being
able to kind of just like clear clear
all the all the messages that you're
hearing and all the programs and all
this repayment stuff and just say okay
hey what can you do how can you take
what you can control and knock this
stuff out and to finally be free of
student loans I mean our last segment
you know there was a 61 year old who had
been paying on it since the 90s so like
99. yeah so you guys I mean this is a
it's a it's a big conversation to have
but also one that we feel like we're
able to help direct and guide you so
make sure to tune into that live stream
it'll be actually Dave you me Jade
warshaw and and we're going to talk
about this and for again a lot of
Americans these payments are going to be
hitting here in the next couple months
and it and it is it is scary right
hundreds of dollars now that you may not
feel like you have the margin for you're
expected to pay so September 12th at 7
pm student loan debt in America how we
got here how we get out go to
ramseysolutions.com student loans sign
up for the free live stream we'll
furnish it to you we're expecting over a
hundred thousand people to view that and
we want you to be one of them spoiler
alert we're going to tell you to pay
them off
I know you're shocked to hear that we're
going to tell you that so just let you
know right up front that's how it is
just like to show you how though as well
walk you through exactly just like we
just did scenarios yeah Shirley is in
San Antonio hi Shirley how are you
guys I'm honored to be speaking to you
today I've been a fan for years well I'm
honored to talk to you how can we help
I want to know if we should help our
daughter pay off some debt
um
she's got
she was in credit card debt a couple of
credit cards about fifty thousand
dollars to a wow and
well back the first of the year she kind
of drank the Kool-Aid and she called him
up and she made a deal with one to pay
on her that card at zero interest the
other one agreed to two percent interest
good so
this girl makes sixty two thousand
dollars a year she's not a girl she's 56
years old
and she is paying these guys 850 a month
and I just feel like I'm watching my
daughter as I rat on a wheel just
what does she make
62 000. so I if you help her are you
giving a drunk a drink or are you
helping her for the last time ever use
she's never going to use credit cards
again as she learned her lesson yeah
yeah
um how much are you going to give her
well
my question to you is
I've heard you in the past tell people
that are in debt like this to call the
credit card like if she knows 20 on
Words is she behind with them
hello
Shirley surely we lost you yeah shoot I
think we lost her if she's if we're
behind try see if you guys can bring her
back up I don't think you can I don't
know I'll put it on hold y'all work on
it um if she is behind you can settle it
for pennies on the dollar if she's
current you can't if she's got a deal
where she's paying them 850 a month you
probably can't if you are going to give
her some money I would only do it on a
matching basis
like every time she sends you a receipt
for uh I don't know how much you want to
give her but if she sends you you know
tell her you're going to give her
every time she puts a thousand in you'll
put a thousand in or something like that
if you got that much money and that's
how much you want to have yeah and
making sure to surely that you are in a
position that you're able to do that
that's assumed and I would dig into like
what that fifty thousand dollars what
like what was that right and understand
that hopefully you know that it doesn't
need to be a pattern in her life that
this is like the thing she just goes to
all the time
um but to really
oh line six good we got her back we got
her back all right
we're about out of time surely but are
you there
I'm here okay is she behind on this debt
no she's not behind then they're not
gonna shuttle with her they're only
going to settle if she's behind how much
how much money have you got
no I mean you're a millionaire
okay yeah so I would not pay it all I
would match whatever she's doing if you
think that her behavior is permanently
changed
no more drinking if you're gonna give a
drunk a drink don't don't be an enabler
but if you're assured that her behavior
is permanently changed and you want to
match her she puts in a thousand you put
in a thousand she puts in a thousand you
put in a thousand that kind of thing I'd
do something like that let her sweat
through this a little bit to solidify
she never does it again
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Proverbs 27 17
is iron sharpens iron so one person
sharpens another
John Wooden said whatever you do in life
surrounds yourself with smart people who
will argue with you
[Laughter]
I have done this this I have done that's
his wise that's an art form for me
that is so great I've never heard that
from wooden very fun retro Cruz Ramsey
personality is my co-host today Tina is
in Pensacola Florida hi Tina how are you
hi Dave how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
hey I have any question I've been
following the baby steps but I
[Music]
um in 2020 we did FPU
and at the same time before the nine
week class was over I was my breast
cancer returned after 10 years of being
gone
so we kind of did things out of order
because of that sleep
um piles of cash that went into the
emergency you know emergency yeah we
don't we don't tell you to work the baby
steps when you're fighting cancer
well we tell you there's pile up cash
I'm stage four so I'm always going to be
fighting
um
so we've paid off 46 988 of debt in
these last three years but I still have
9052 to go
and we have our fully funded emergency
funds almost fully funded it's twelve
thousand dollars and I'm just I'm asking
you to get that nine grand gone at the
same time I'm scared to take out the
emergency fund and pay off that debt
what type of cancer do you have kiddo
how old are you
okay
and so it came back with a vengeance
three years it's been 10 years
yeah
that's an eight and then it came back in
2010. and then both of that was
destroying occurrence and then in August
of this month August 2020 it came back
as stage four
in my lungs I'm sorry I'm sorry
um okay stable but I'm still I'll be in
treatment forever so
obviously yeah
um so what yeah I don't think this is a
baby I I would not say you do the baby
steps normally when someone's going
through a chemo and trying to get
towards remission which is not your
diagnosis
um correct but uh uh we would say stop
everything don't work on the baby steps
pile up cash fight cancer in your case
you're electing to fight cancer while
having some savings and fight debt right
correct and so we're not going to call
this the baby steps this is just your
choice instead of just piling up cash
only you're saying part of my walk is I
want to go ahead and hit this debt
right that's what I'm hearing okay so I
just I want you to I want you to know
what you're doing is you're saying it's
a modified version of piling up cash is
all it is
okay
it's not a modified version of the baby
steps and that's okay I mean it's a
nuanced difference but so the point
being that there's not a a baby steps
answer to this it's more of a thing of
you have how much in in your emergency
fund now
192.98 and what's your household income
tax and you have nine thousand dollars
in debt left
nine thousand dollars and fifty cents or
nine thousand dollars nine thousand
fifty two dollars yes
I mean we're able to perform our
expenses
Twenty One Hundred a month because we
own our house
um but in Florida we're getting hit high
with insurance
insurance so um our expenses are 2100 a
month so we have I've been putting 1800
a month well fifteen hundred a month
towards that 300 a month yeah keeping it
for other things that come up that
aren't planned for so we don't have to
touch our emergency fund sure okay
here's the well here's the way I'm
analyzing this and you you tell me if
I'm wrong because I I don't know but
in sitting in this seat I've had this
discussion with people
lots of times over the last 30 years
okay and so what I understand about
cancer and I've never had it and I've
not had you know my spouse fighting it
but I've had lots of friends and lots of
people sitting in the seat I've talked
to about it it's very very important
that you focus on winning the battle
right
yes I mean you have to focus your
emotional energy your spiritual energy
on
be on winning right now and and so
having said that then I would tell you
that whether you add to the savings or
whether you pay down on the debt
the answer is which one gives you the
most peace because I want you to have
the most peace so you can concentrate on
the most important things living
okay that makes sense
there's not a wrong answer yeah so for
for you Tina you may say I would feel
more peace with this nine thousand
dollars gone you know like or for some
people it's like nope the minimum
payment's fine I just want some cash
over here right so it's kind of this you
choose your journey with where you're at
of what gives what what gives Tina the
most peace because you need you need
peace because you need power
right and and boy look at you've got an
amazing you've got an amazing tone to
your voice I'll just tell you there's a
lot of joy in your voice
there is a lot of peace that I have and
I the reason I was getting six hours to
live I'm 36 months later and I'm good so
um
yeah yes so and talk about it with your
spouse too I mean what gives you guys
the best quality of life right now
um and
you know it might be that you know we'd
rather instead of having twelve thousand
we'd rather have 22 000 um or instead of
having twelve thousand I'd rather have
three thousand and no debt
um you know what you know Rachel's right
you choose your journey and that's what
I'm telling you because that all of that
is a modified version of piling up cash
the reason for piling up cash and
pushing pause on the traditional baby
steps is to give you the power the
emotional spiritual and even Financial
power to lean into this fight and uh to
enjoy the ride uh and uh so as much as
you can and and that's what we want for
you so
um
you're smart you're game on there's not
a thing in the stupid column
fight fight fight that's what's that
that's what that's what we want for you
we want you to have the the Peace of a
warrior to fight and and to go into this
and and not be going oh I'm doing this
wrong by Ramsey you're not there's not a
wrong pile up cash or pay off debt what
gives you the most power what gives you
the most peace
so reminder when you have storm clouds
in your life folks or when you have a
unexpected thing you get a job layoff
you get a a baby on the way you're
fighting you get a cancer diagnosis you
get a whatever like this it's not
modifying yourself you just stop the
baby steps and pile up cash you can come
back later with a pilocation restart
so if you pile up 50 Grand follow up 100
Grand and you know you could push play
again and run the table Yeah on baby
steps one through three you know just
just like that you know if you got a big
old pile of cash but in the meantime you
can concentrate on what's important
which in that moment
is the storm yeah get it running into
the storm not from the storm that's
right and uh
it's the old story of the Buffaloes on
the planes run into the storm that way
they're in the storm not as long because
the storm goes over them faster since
they're running into it and cattle run
with the storm so they end up staying in
the storm so be the buffalo
be the Buffalo run into the storm that
that's the old story and that's that's
the thing so ah I'm sorry for praying
for you girl if you can help you in any
way your husband anyway y'all call us
and let us know we'll help you any way
we can this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
okay
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]